algunos en genes es la alegría por el
fin del encierro y por el día del barco
del dragón una festividad que se celebra
hoy en toda china les ha durado muy poco
las autoridades han detectado nuevos
contagios en la comunidad es decir fuera
de los centros de cuarentena son siete
los primeros en tres días situados en
los distritos de pudong y jingan así que
se ha ordenado otra cuarentena
domiciliaria en cuatro barrios que se
alargará al menos durante dos semanas
además los 26 contactos más cercanos y
los más de 100 contactos secundarios han
sido conducidos a centros de cuarentena
el paso atrás revela la dificultad de
controlar la variante omicron en una
ciudad tan densamente poblada como
shanghai incluso después de un encierro
de más de dos meses fue levantado en la
medianoche del miércoles en muchos
shanghaineses corrieron a la calle a
celebrarlo en algunos casos sin respetar
la distancia social que recomiendan las
autoridades tras la reapertura siguen
los controles es obligatorio un test
cada 72 horas y para engrasar el proceso
se han levantado más de 15.000 puestos
en toda la ciudad en jaén s sin embargo
lamentaban hoy que han tenido que
soportar largas colas bajo el sol
veraniego